this guy he doesn't like to play long
matches that's for sure because it's yet
to be a single for matt for game match
um
yeah um
i think first game
as i said he just i just got a piece and
i think
second game yeah i was just worse so i
think that that's what this best chance
was
uh in the second game to win
i think third game
um
i started to play passively in the in
the opening but then when i got this h4
f4 i i think it's already a bit
dangerous for black
uh in rapid
how do you
refocus after losing three games in a
row to magnus yesterday um
yeah i think
losing three games was okay because i
played well in the first and second game
so
i think it was fine for me um
i just thought it's okay because
i played well and
let me play my best just in the
remaining tournament uh that's what my
mindset was but this is interesting
because the matches you've won you've
usually said that you've played quite
poorly and the match you lost you're
saying that you played well um i mean
probably not great but
uh
good chest for uh rapid i'd say you're
creating great entertainment for us
thank you so much park yeah thank you
so that is uh